well let me ask you a human question
here you you've uh in the game design
space you've done a lot of incredible
work throughout but in terms of game
design
you have changed the world and there's a
few people around you that did the same
so famously there's some animosity
there's much love but there's some
animosity between you and john romero
what is at the core of that animosity
and human tension and so there really
hasn't been i
for a long time and even at the
beginning it's like yes i am
i did push romero out of the company and
and this is one of the things that i
look back if i could go back telling my
my younger self
some advice about things
the original
founding
kind of corporate structure of id
software
really led to a bunch of problems we
started off with us as equal partners
and we had a buy sell agreement because
we didn't want outsiders to be telling
us what to do inside the company and
that did lead to a bunch of the problems
where i was sitting here going
it's like all right i'm i'm working
harder than anyone i'm doing these
technologies
you know nobody's done before but we're
all equal partners and then i see you
know somebody that's not working as hard
and i'm
and it's i mean i can't say i was the
most mature about that i was you know 20
something years old and i am
and it did it did bother me when i'm
like everybody okay we need all pull
together and we've done it before
everybody we know we can do this if we
get together and we grind it all out but
not everybody wanted to do that for
for all time you know and i was the
youngest one of the the crowd there i i
had different sets of uh kind of
backgrounds and motivations and left at
that point where
it was i'm all right either everybody
has to be contributing like up to this
level or they need to get pushed out was
not i am that was not a great situation
and i look back on it and no that we
pushed people out of the company that
could have contributed uh if there was a
different framework for them and the
modern kind of silicon valley like let
your stock vest over a time period and
maybe it's non-voting stock and all
those different things we knew nothing
about any of that i mean we we didn't
know what we were doing in terms of
corporate structure or anything so if
you think the framework was different
some of the human tension could have
been a little bit it almost certainly
would have i i mean i look back at that
and
and it's like even trying to summon up
in my mind it's like i know i was really
really angry about i am you know like
romero not working as hard as i wanted
him to work or not carrying his load on
the design for quake and coming up with
things there but you know he was
definitely doing things he made some of
the best levels there he was working
with our uh some of our external teams
like raven on the licensing side of
things but i am you know but there were
differences of opinion uh about it but
he landed you know right on his feet he
went he got 20 million dollars from idos
to go do ion storm and he got to do
things his way and spun up three teams
simultaneously because that was always
one of the one of the challenging things
in it id where we were doing these
single string one project after another
and i think some of them you know wanted
to grow the company more and i didn't
because i knew people that were saying
that oh companies turned to [ __ ] when
you got 50 employees i it's just a
different world there and i loved our
little
dozen people working on the projects but
you can look at it and say well business
realities matter it's like you're super
successful here and we could we could
take a swing and a miss on something but
you do it a couple times and you're out
of luck uh there's
there's a reason companies try to have
multiple teams running at one time i am
and so that was again something i didn't
really appreciate back then
so if you look past all that you did
create some amazing things together what
did you love about john romero what did
you respect and appreciate about what
did you admire about him what did you
learn from him
when i met him he was the coolest
programmer i had ever met i you know he
had done all of this stuff he had he had
made all of these games he had worked at
uh you know one of the companies that i
thought was the coolest at origin
systems and he knew all this stuff he
made things happen fast and he could it
was also kind of a polymath about this
where he could do he made his own he
drew his own art he made his own levels
as well as um you know he worked on
sound design systems on top of actually
being a really good programmer and we
had you know we went through
a little it was kind of fun where one of
the early things that we did where there
was kind of the young buck bit going in
where i was uh the new guy and he was
the kind of the he was the top man
programmer at the soft disk area and
eventually we had sort of a challenge
over the weekend that we were going to
like race to to implement this game to
port one of our pc games back down to
the apple too and that was where we
finally kind of became clear it's like
okay carmack stands a little bit apart
on the programming side of things and uh
but romero then very gracefully moved
into well he'll work on the tools he'll
work on the systems uh do some of the
game design stuff as well as
contributing on uh starting to lead the
design aspects of a lot of things
so he was you know enormously valuable
in the early stuff and so much of doom
uh and even quake have his stamp on it
in a lot of ways but i am
you know he wasn't at the same level of
focus that that i brought to the the
work that we were doing there and he
really did
i
we hit such a degree of success
it was all in the press about that the
the rockstar game programmers yeah yeah
it's the beatles problem yeah i mean
you know he ate it up and he did
personified there was the whole game
developers with uh you know with
ferraris that uh that we had there
and i thought that you know that led to
some
some challenges there
but so much of the
uh you know the stuff that was great in
the games did come from him and i would
certainly not take that away from him
and even after i after we parted ways
and he took his swing with uh with idos
in some ways he was like he was ahead of
the curve with mobile gaming as well
where
one of his companies after idos was
working on feature phone game
development and i wound up doing some of
that uh just before the iphone crossing
over into the iphone phase there and
that was something that clearly did turn
out to be a huge thing although he was
he was too early for what he was working
on at that time
you know we've had uh pretty you know
cordial relationships where i was happy
to talk with him anytime i'd run into
him at at a conference i have actually
had some other people just say it's like
oh you shouldn't you know you shouldn't
go over there and give him the time of
day or felt that
masters of doom was i
you know like portray played things up
in a way that i shouldn't be too happy
with but i'm i'm okay with all of that
and you've got love in your heart yeah i
mean i just talked with him by like last
year or i guess it was even this year
about mentioning that i'm going off
doing this ai stuff i'm i'm going big
into artificial intelligence and he had
a bunch of ideas for how ai is going to
play into gaming and you know asked if i
was interested in collaborating and it's
not in line with what with what i'm
doing but i do you know i wish almost
everyone the best i mean i i know i may
not have partnered on the best of terms
with uh you know with some people but i
was thrilled to see tom hall i writing
vr games now he wrote working on a game
called demio which is
really an awesome vr game it's like
dungeons and dragons we all used to play
dungeons and dragons together that was
one of the things that was what we did
on sundays in the early days i would
dungeon master and they'd all play and i
you know so it really made me smile
seeing tom involved with an rpg game in
virtual reality
you